this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode we've finally broken
jonathan by showing him the madcap guns
of the time splitters franchise this is
some unholy cursed agglomeration of a
desert eagle and a beretta basically
it's like a desert eagle has been shoved
up a beretta 92 which is uh not a happy
experience for anyone concerned frankly
so uh good job guys you've beaten me if
there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below make sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and if you'd like to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
[Music]
well this is an interesting one it looks
an awful lot like a luger but it's like
it's got some sort of additional barrel
shroud thing on it that makes it look a
lot more advanced but it even has an
animated toggle lock on the top of it
it's animated far too slowly the barrel
is recoiling and the toggle is flipping
far too slowly it's like it's on slow
motion but that's not uncommon in games
i noticed that they have actually got
the cartridge cases ejecting out of the
top of the pistol which is nice although
they haven't stayed very faithful to the
luger design they have reflected how it
actually operates with the toggle lock
and the vertical ejection clearly this
is a time travel based game so we are in
the past i don't know if this is meant
to be some futuristic gun based on the
luger that we brought with us or if this
is meant to be what a luger looks like
in this universe maybe it's a bit of
both maybe it's meant to pass as a
weapon of the period but a luger with a
silencer on it does not fit the 1920s
1930s whatever this is supposed to be
but it does fit the 1940s behold
the luger with a silencer on it or a
suppressor if you're pedantic and i am
but it depends which mood i'm in so this
is one of a number of lugers that was
produced for special operations
executive the british equivalent of the
oss and it's a standard dwm
nine millimeter luger that's had the
barrel threaded for
a parker hail
sound suppressor which has a little bead
front sight
set into the
the body
so yeah there is actually a period
precedent that i very much doubt the
developers of this game were aware of
for a silenced luger it doesn't it even
looks quite similar if we were able to
fill this bit in with some sort of
shroud we would have the time splitters
gun so i think that's quite
fun
there's a lot to take in here the gun
itself is pretty close to an ak but not
quite right we've got some strange lumps
on the side of the gun it's mirrored so
it's a left-handed gun but broadly it is
an ak or an aks except that it has this
amusing white folding wire stock which
has it has big lugs on the gun that
don't exist on the real ak stopping it
from folding up and over and in fact the
cocking handle would also stop it from
folding up and over the gun as well and
because it's a u-shaped bit of wire over
the top of the gun it couldn't underfold
either so there's there's actually no
way to deploy this stock the grenade
launcher is a little bit half-life in
that it's sort of an afterthought a
couple of tubes stuck to the bottom of
the hand guard so i knew i knew there
was something similar coming up so i
grabbed something similar from our
collection now this is a polish pmk ms
which is the polish copy of the akms now
this has the opposite stock problem to
the time splitters rifle in that its
normal ak underfolding stock can't be
folded because of the grenade launcher
so a very different design to the m203
look-alike that's on this ak but it's
it's a real-world equivalent of what
we're seeing
in the game
[Music]
interesting take on the mini gun i
couldn't help noticing the red and white
candy stripe portion on the rear of the
gun not really sure what that's about
the feed and ejection
on the same side of the gun so you've
got a shoot of rounds going up into the
gun and then immediately reversing after
being fired and
shooting out the left side presumably so
that you can see more of what's going on
with the fun animations that's not how a
minigun works miniguns as you'd have
seen the classic scene from the matrix
with the helicopter the empty case is
dropped from the bottom of the gun so
it's uh some liberties taken there with
the minigun design well across the board
really it doesn't really look like a
minigun in detail something a bit
different i think a couple of points
we've got the barrels just spinning
without firing and i've played at least
one game where you can spool up the gun
with one button and fire it with another
so i don't know if that's what was
happening there it didn't seem like it
was just a normal delay it's like just
just spinning away it's kind of an
interesting one because the the delay in
firing with a mini gun and get in games
is basically artificial in the first
place mini guns yes they sort of spool
up in that they have to reach the first
firing position but they do that almost
instantly and that's it it's a gameplay
mechanic to begin with to make the thing
more cumbersome to use that you have to
sort of think ahead of when you need to
press the trigger so to have a way to
shortcut that is kind of funny really
that there's a gameplay way to remove
the gameplay mechanic
[Music]
so this this is extremely reminiscent of
the wa2000 it's got similar muzzle
device similar barrel support similar
architecture square blocky design wooden
furniture uncommon on a modern sniper
rifle even in the 70s when this was
designed they've somehow made it less of
a ballpark so i think it's technically i
think it technically still would be one
in that the trigger is is just about in
front of wherever the breach is on this
thing but it is not nearly so clearly a
ballpark if that makes sense uh the
scope is a little bizarre in that it
looks like a conventional scope for the
most part but then when you actually use
the scope it's like this weird
rectangular
thermal looking reticle scope view thing
it doesn't quite seem to jibe with how
it's depicted on the gun itself and
clearly with with some strong golden eye
heritage behind it we are for some
reason wielding a sniper rifle
one-handed even though
from an external view almost certainly
just like golden eye you would be
holding it with both hands some weird
quirk of graphics engine or limitations
of the time meaning that from first
person you are ostensibly one one-handed
wielding but actually you're not because
otherwise you wouldn't be able to shoot
this is quite an intriguing one i think
it's a riff on on the pulse rifle from
aliens it's green it's got the big
grooved carrying handle on it with sort
of launcher looking section underneath
and there are there are some sort of
pink plasma charges that you can use um
as like an old fire it's more like a
combination of the pulse rifle and the
plasma rifle from terminator and
interestingly and see from the the um
hud indicator it not only overheats but
speeds up its own rate of fire in a sort
of curve the more you hold down the
trigger so you get more effect more
firepower but you you have to walk a
line of more firepower but your gun's
gonna stop if you push it too hard or
you just push it too hard let it cool
down and shoot again which is probably
what i would do which is interesting
i've not seen that take on a energy
weapon overheating before but we also do
have ammunition so it isn't just the
straightforward heating up of an energy
based weapon it is more like the doom
plasma rifle where you have ammo it is
like a riff on the pulse rifle but it's
pretty far from the tree in design terms
quite a heavy-duty looking grenade
launcher here quite an interesting
design too looks an awful lot like
they've taken the textures for the
rounds are actual an actual round of
what looks to be 303 i'm pretty sure i
can see 0.303 on the case head and i
think the other markings are probably
consistent with 303 british as well
which is quite funny so that would be a
rimmed rifle cartridge not a grenade
launcher round but for visual texture
i'm pretty sure i can even see the
staked primer of a wartime 303 round and
what looks like the war department arrow
as well so that's a bizarre bit of
firearms history buried in this console
game as to how it works anyone's guess
really some sort of recoil operation
going on a great big bolt assembly is
coming back
not really sure why because it's a
rotary it's a revolver type weapon all
you need is a firing mechanism to fire
each round and then the magazine system
or the feed mechanism rotates to the
next shot so i don't know why you would
need a big artillery style breech but it
does look cool the rounds look like they
would fall out if you've aimed this
thing upward at all you'll notice most
most drum magazines most revolvers have
some way of mechanically preventing
rounds from just falling out of the
cylinder and this doesn't have that so
that we can see those textures in all of
their
glory it looks like a fun video game
grenade launcher not based on anything
in particular but it is its own design
right now i'm getting major golden eye
vibes from the dual wield p90s we've got
some an excessively high magazine
capacity the p90 is 50 rounds this is
over 60 by the look of it we're
sufficiently early that the rounds
aren't being animated they're just a
static texture that's fair enough it has
got some sort of weird futuristic
thermal optic thing on it and then it's
got some sort of light laser unit on the
right hand side now the there's a
version of the p90 that does allow that
this isn't it otherwise it is not a bad
representation of a p90 much better than
golden eyes was several years before
this and it's got the right kind of rate
of fire actually the p90 does does hum
however we have got some rather tiny
cartridge cases that smaller than the
cartridges that are depicted in the
magazine that are flying out of the left
side of the gun now they should be
dropping out of the bottom of the gun if
this was a p90
we've uh moved into the future now
appropriately enough this is clearly a a
different game in the franchise with
better graphics just vaguely reminiscent
of a p90 is this assault rifle thing so
it has another sort of non-functional
futuristic looking optic on top of it
it's moved very far from the p90 design
but it's recognizably similar to the
time splitters 2 take on the p90 so in
design terms that's quite interesting um
it reminds me of something from one of
the later deus ex games the way you open
up the gun
and remove the magazine like it's a
coffee machine or something when you're
replacing the
water tank which i guess fits that sort
of mass-produced product idea of a
futuristic gun it's got the very high
rate of fire and the weird highly
pitched report of a sci-fi gun as well
so though it's ostensibly fire encased
ammunition for some reason it sounds
different and has a very high rate of
fire but is controllable and who knows
what technology might exist in the
future to control recoil we're going to
need it if we're going to go for these
super high pressure rounds that the
united states are currently looking at
[Music]
well that was truly bizarre i don't
quite know what to make of that except
it's some kind of folding compact design
that opens out into a gun it's got a
super high rate of fire and that
futuristic firing sound effect it's
literally got monkey written on the side
of it and what appears to be a
representation of a monkey in the site
which is a as per usual non-functional
you can't use it for anything just as
well really not sure how you aim using a
cartoon monkey so they seem to have gone
with this and the other future assault
rifle they seem to be going for very
high capacity and very high rate of fire
but then reload times have gone up over
modern firearms can reload a modern
assault rifle in a matter of a second
these not so much they've been
re-engineered for the game effectively
to make them slower to reload for
gameplay reasons
[Music]
this is another fascinating weapon that
i'm still trying to puzzle out so it's
um a kind of a diesel punk take on a
crossbow really it's got a drum some
sort of drum magazine what i can't tell
is how and where the harpoons are
feeding from when you hit something with
them they're big chunky arrow-like
projectiles but they i don't see where
those live on the gun we've got a set of
cogs on there which are fun and i guess
the idea is some sort of explosive
charge is causing a bolt to recoil and
then the sort of rack and pinion is
driving the magazine to turn it to the
next shot the fun thing about that as an
idea is that it has the gameplay
mechanic of recoverable ammunition so
you could literally run up to the zombie
you just turned into a pincushion and
pick up one or more of the of the rounds
so that even if you're out of ammo
you're not out of ammo
so at first glance this thing looks like
some sort of homemade craft produced
submachine gun it looks like it could
function but it's a kind of a bit over
designed as a lot of um fictional video
game guns are there's a lot of a lot of
design features there that wouldn't do
anything other than look cool extra
interesting is the fact that this is
firing rifle grenades from its muzzle
which is something i don't think i've
ever seen done in a game now firing
rifle grenades off a sub machine gun is
not and it's something that anyone has
ever done unless you count the under
barrel launchers that exist for things
like the mp5 and yes they do exist we
have one a submachine gun is too small
and light to effectively allow you to
launch a grenade like this although some
versions of it you can fire from the
shoulder typically it requires a
big chunky heavy rifle and you need to
put the butt into the ground and fire at
an angle and let the ground take the
recoil this thing just we're just taking
it with our arm muscles but it's
very interesting to see a version of a
rifle grenade in such a far-fetched
video game
the flare gun is pretty close to
the first world war single barrel
luftwaffe signal pistol flare gun
whatever you want to call it which
actually did have as an option grenade
rounds which is what we're seeing here i
mean the the shot where it sets someone
on fire is closer to a standard flare
round although that isn't really how
they work being designed to create a
bright light up in the sky they just
like they did go far enough into you to
stay there they would just burn whatever
color they're supposed to burn they
wouldn't set you on fire but it's quite
an interesting
game gun in that it's pretty close to a
real flare gun but has a lot of gameplay
potential being single shot but quite
effective which a grenade round out of a
flare gun would be right so now i'm
seeing the ammunition actually doing its
intended thing it sort of spirals off
into the sky and bursts into a bit like
a flare but it doesn't sort of it's more
like a star shell illumination flare
maybe although it doesn't seem that
bright it's certainly not a
standard coloured parachute flare or
anything like that practically speaking
it's a grenade round though
this is very much a legally different
heckler and [ __ ] mp5k
and it's quite different in detail as
most of the time splitters guns are a
bit of a mishmash the cocking handle is
not your classic hk shape it's more just
a normal round knob that's quite
deliberate design choice for whatever
reason the front grip looks quite
different in fact overall it almost
looks a bit like the experimental hk smg
than the 80s 90s but it's mainly mp5k so
when we only had one of them we're
getting a version of the hk slap when
we're dual wielding them the bolts just
go forward on their own because how else
are you going to do it interesting
little detail though at this stage of of
game design cartridge cases in mid-air
which are flying perpendicular to the
gun which is a
they should be flying in an arc but
nonetheless um i can see the the case
head and there is a bit of detail there
including a fired primer so despite the
guns being quite fantasy takes on real
guns and then some made up ones we have
got little details like a dented primer
on a fired cartridge case
[Music]
if i was disappointed by the syringe gun
from team fortress
this kind of makes up for it so we're
firing some sort of dart that injects
compressed air this looks to be an air
tank on the gun itself i'm not sure how
that helps the darts to inflate targets
but nonetheless the the effect on target
is that they are injected with an
implausible amount of compressed air or
gas and then they burst it's pretty cool
if a bit grim as with other weapons in
this game or this series i'm struggling
to imagine how this thing would function
so we've got compressed gas on the gun
for some reason i think just as a visual
indicator of how the of what the gun is
and then we have a reciprocating bolt
which could mean a magazine in the grip
except the darts look like they must be
pretty big and they'd have to be very
big to contain enough compressed gas to
actually inflate a person to the point
of exploding it's a fantasy gun
this is some unholy cursed agglomeration
of a desert eagle and a beretta
basically it's like a desert eagle has
been shoved up a beretta 92 which is uh
not a happy experience for anyone
concerned frankly at least of all me
watching it so uh good job guys you've
beaten me and then it's got a sort of
accessory suppressor that has a scope
mount built into it which is all kinds
of wrong as well you need a scope or any
any optical sight needs to be mounted to
something solid that doesn't move so a
detachable part of the gun is not
normally a good place to mount an
optical sight yeah i i think i think
enough said on that one
right pause it i'm pausing right away
there to say what the hell what a
bizarre weapon this this is vaguely
reminiscent of the the neo pup although
the um ntw 20 the south african grenade
launcher that has a grip unit mounted on
the side of it on the right side of it
this is the other way around similar
arrangement and then it has a curved
rocket magazine that wraps around your
forearm and then the front of the gun is
basically just a launch platform for the
rocket might even be plausible to make
something like this one day i don't know
so there's a weird auto loader that
grabs a rocket from the effectively box
magazine at the rear and then conveys it
in an arc forwards onto the front of the
gun where it's ignited and does its
thing now that's vaguely plausible in
that a rocket munition is a weapon in
its own right and the thing you shoot it
from is just a launch platform there are
guided missiles that are literally just
a missile that you stick on a little
ramp and launch them so this is weirdly
enough one of the more plausible weapons
in this game
well i hope you enjoyed that guys i
think that one may have broken my brain
as ever if you'd like to support the
work that we do here at the royal
armouries bringing you some interesting
things to complement the reviews that i
do we have links in the description for
that we've also got a series of videos
on the royal armouries youtube channel
and stuff going on on social media
facebook and instagram that you might
want to check out as well and please do
come and visit us here in leeds down at
fort nelson or at the tower of london if
you can and see you again next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
you